Transcriber: Selen Yetiş
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
Herkese selamlar. Ben Kaan.
Onedio.com'un kurucusuyum.
''TED'de konuşma yapmak
ister misin?'' dediler.
Gurur duyarım dedim.
Ne anlatacağım? Momentum dediler.
Ben elektronik mühendisiyim.
Momentum denilince benim aklıma
kütle çarpı hız geliyor.
Yani bunu nasıl anlatacağım?
Bir Google'a gireyim, momentum yazayım
bakalım benim bilmediğim başka anlamı
var mı konuşmamı üzerine kurabileceğim
diye Google'a girdim.
Momentum yazdım.
Yani beklenildiği gibi kütle çarpı
hız çıktı.
Ama orada çok kritik bir nokta vardı.
Momentum vektörel bir niceliktir.
Yani bir yönü ve büyüklüğü vardır diyordu.
Ben de konuşmamı bunun üzerine
kurgulamaya karar verdim.
Şimdi momentum sanki
hep iyi bir şey gibi anlatıyoruz.
Ama söylediğim gibi bunun bir yönü var.
Hayatımızda hep momentum bize
pozitif etkide bulunmuyor.
O kadar kötü zamanlar geçiriyoruz ki.
Yani bu dibe vuruşlarımız da
aslında bir momentum.
Ama önemli olan o
dibe vurduğumuz anlardan nasıl çıkıyoruz?
Girişimcilik hayatımdan örneklerle,
keyifli örneklerle, eğlenceli örneklerle.
Ankaralı, memur çocuğu,
bir elektronik mühendisi nasıl geldi;
şuan İstanbul'da dijital medya sektörünü
değiştirmeye çalışıyor,
bu noktaya nasıl geldim
onu anlatmak istiyorum.
Şimdi bahsettiğim gibi aslında hayat da
iş dünyası da hep böyle gidiyor.
İşte yukarı momentumlar
aşağı momentumlar.
Sonunda amaç o dibe vurduğunuz noktadan
tecrübe ile daha yukarıya çıkmak.
Yıl 2005, ODTÜ Elektronik Mühendisliği
son sınıf öğrencisiyim.
Bitirme projemiz var.
Bitirme projemiz:
Bir tane eğik düzlem var,
eğik düzlem üzerine çiviler çakılmış,
bir tane pinpon topu bırakılıyor tepeden.
O pinpon topu çivilere çarpa çarpa
rastgele bir yerden düşüyor.
Bizim projemiz de bunu yakalayacak
robot bir kol yapmak.
Bir tane kamera koyduk.
Kamera topun hareketlerini analiz edip,
o robot kolu hareket ettirerek
topun yakalanmasını sağlıyor.
Çok güzel bir proje oldu.
Bununla uğraşırken bir gün
arkadaşlarla oturuyoruz.
İşte üniversite ortamı.
Başka bir arkadaş geldi muhabbete yeni.
Dedi ki: "Abi bugün halı sahada
o kadar güzel bir gol attım ki,
keşke bunun videosu olsaydı da
size gösterebilseydim."
Orada hemen tabi biz de dedik pinpon
topunu takip edebiliyoruz kamerayla.
Herhalde halı sahada da
futbol topunu takip ederiz.
Bir tane kamera sistemi yaparız,
maçları kaydeder.
Böylece insanlar da işte
güzel hareketlerini, güzel gollerini
maç sonrası arkadaşlarına gösterirler.
İşte süper fikir, parayı vurduk.
Türkiye'de on iki bin tane halı saha var.
Bin tanesi alsa, tanesi on bin liradan
on milyon dolar...
Oh yürüdük.
Tabii aile memur olunca,
üniversite de bitecek,
beklenti işte oğlum Türkiye'nin
en iyi okullarından birinde okudun.
Gir işte ASELSAN'da çalış,
Turkcell'de çalış.
Türkiye'nin büyük şirketlerinden
birinde çalış.
Ben dedim: "Baba işte halı sahalarda
top takip sistemi yapacağım."
(Gülüşmeler)
Annem bir süre konuşmadı benimle,
babam harçlıkları kesti.
Ama biz bu işe devam ettik ortakla.
Tam da o zaman "Yeni Fikirler Yeni İşler"
yarışması var ODTÜ'de.
O yarışmaya katıldık bu fikirle.
O yarışmada da ikinci olduk.
Bize on bin lira verdiler,
bir de ofis verdiler.
Her şey müthiş gidiyor,
momentumu almışız.
Başladık biz halı saha halı saha
dolaşmaya.
Yani sistemi yaptık.
Benim ortağım Demirhan,
teknik tarafı yapıyor;
ben de satışı üstlendim.
Ankara, İstanbul ve İzmir'deki bütün
halı sahaları dolaştım.
Bir tane satabildim.
(Gülüşmeler)
6 ay önce her şey çok güzel giderken
birdenbire öğle yemeklerinde evden
ekmek arası salam kaşar
getirdiğimiz bir noktaya geldik.
Kara kara düşünüyoruz ne yapacağız,
ne edeceğiz diye.
Ondan sonra baktık bizim çok
güzel bir teknolojimiz var aslında orada.
Şampiyonlar Ligi maçlarında hani
kim kaç kilometre koştu gösterilir ya.
Biz aynı şeyi yapıyoruz aslında.
Kameradan insanları ve topu
takip edebiliyoruz.
Bu teknoloji ile neler yapabiliriz
diye araştırmaya başladık
ve insan sayma sistemi diye
bir şeyin popüler olduğunu gördük.
Yani kamera koyuyorsunuz mağaza girişine,
alışveriş merkezi girişine.
Giren çıkan insanı sayıyor,
işte hangi saatlerde kaç kişi giriyor,
giren kişilerin kaçı alışveriş yapıyor
gibi çok güzel bir
business analytics veren bir sistem var.
Yurtdışında yeni trend oluyor.
Biz hemen sistemi buraya değiştirdik.
Yani halı sahada takip ettiğimiz adamları
alışveriş merkezinde takip etmeye başladık
ve bu sistem gerçekten tuttu.
Çok güzel işler almaya başladık.
İşte İstanbul'da Kanyon Alışveriş Merkezi,
Cevahir Alışveriş Merkezi,
havaalanlarındaki free shoplar, vs.
Gerçekten işler güzel gidiyor.
Sonra bize dediler ki:
"Ya siz insan sayıyorsanız
çuval da sayarsınız."
"E sayarız."
Gittik işte çimento fabrikasında,
şeker fabrikasında çuval saydık.
Sonra dediler:
"Siz insan sayıyorsunuz, çuval
sayıyorsunuz. Zeytin sayabilir misiniz?"
"Sayarız." dedik.
Mamara Birlik'e gittik zeytin saydık.
Sonra araç saymaya başladık trafikte,
bu EDS sistemlerine geçtik.
İşler her yerden gelmeye başladı bize.
(Gülüşmeler)
Ben 2010 yılında Hac'a gittim,
Mekke'ye koyun saymaya.
Orada 4milyon tane koyun kesiliyormuş.
İşler çok güzel.
Ama yine her zaman ki gibi 1 saniye
sonra olacak kötü şeyi göremiyorsunuz.
Türkmenistan'da bir projemiz vardı.
Türkmenistan bayağı değişik bir yer.
Nasıl anlatsam bilemiyorum ama.
Böyle bir presidenti var, başkan.
Darbe ile, yani orada seçim yok.
Her president darbe ile geliyor
ve önceki tüm yönetimi öldürüyorlar,
asıyorlar falan.
Değişik bir ülke yani.
O presidentin her gün kullandığı yolda
biz oraya plaka tanıma sistemi koyacağız.
Yani oradan geçen tüm araçların
plakalarını okuyacağız
ve onu sisteme kaydedeceğiz.
Çok güzel bir proje, çok büyük bir proje.
Benim ortağım artı 5 tane bizim ekipten
mühendis
Türkmenistan'a giti.
Şimdi çok güvenlikli bir proje ya
girerken bunların pasaportlarına
el koydular.
Dediler ki işte bu proje tamamlanınca
size vereceğiz pasaportları, gideceksiniz.
Bizim tahminimiz 2-3 haftada proje biter,
dönerizdi.
En son 4 ay geçmişti, benim ortağım
beni arıyordu:
"Kaan buraya gel! Bizi kurtar,
bizi buradan göndermiyorlar."
Mühendislerin aileleri arıyor:
"Oğlumuz nerede, ne yapacağız?
Artık sorumluları devreye sokalım."
Ben de diyorum ki:
"Buraya yeni gelen president
orada iş yapan bir Türk iş adamının,
önceki presidentle iş yaptığı için
tüm mal varlığına el koydu,
ülkeden çıkmasını engelledi.
Onu Türkiye'ye getirmek için
Cumhurbaşkanlığı'nın Ata Uçağı'nın
gitmesi gerekti."
Yani ben de Ata Uçağı'nı gönderemeyeceğime
göre
bu işi bir şekilde çözmemiz lazım.
Problem de şu: Şimdi biliyorsunuz
plakalar gece üstüne ışık vurunca parlar.
Reflektör bir yüzeyi vardır onun.
Türkmenistan'daki devlet plaklarında da
bu reflektörlü yüzey yokmuş.
O yüzden gece biz devlet plakalarını
okuyamıyoruz ki president de
asıl devlet plakalarından korkuyor.
O yüzden diyorlar ki
sizin sisteminiz çalışmıyor.
Bu sistemi tamamlamadan
buradan adam çıkmaz.
İşte ortağım arıyor.
"Kaan gel kurtar beni.
Farelerle birlikte yaşıyoruz burada,
kiralık evde."
Bir de o arada Türkiye'de olan
projeler de sekteye uğradı.
Bizim 6 kişi orada.
Türkiye'de iş olmuyor, para dönmüyor.
Birden bire bakmışız biz
işler çok güzel giderken
bankalara, sağa sola 700bin lira
borçlanmışız.
Bayağı dibe çökmüş bir duruma gelmişiz.
İşleri tamamlayamıyoruz.
Artık en son ODTÜ'den bilgisayar
mühendisliği bölüm başkanı
sağolsun bir yazı yazdı.
Teknik olarak bu mümkün değildir,
plakaların yenilenmesi
gerekmektedir diye.
O yazı gitti oraya, bakanlığa vesaire.
Çözüldü, sonra neyse geldi arkadaşlar.
Ama tabii biz de orda işler bayağı
dibe vurma noktasına gelmişti.
Dönünce zaten 5 mühendisin
5'i de istifa etti.
Ortağım da neredeyse istafa edecekti,
o edemedi.
Bir şekilde biz ne yapacağız diye
yeniden düşünmeye başladık.
Yine çok radikal bir karar verdik
ve insan sayma sistemi dışındaki
tüm ürünlerimizi öldürdük.
Yani milyonlarca lira para harcadığımız,
aylarca üstünde emek olan,
işte plaka tanıma sistemleri olsun,
trafik analiz sistemleri olsun,
diğer sayma sistemleri olsun
hepsini ortadan kaldırdık
ve tek bir ürüne odaklandık.
Bu bizim gerçekten
o negatif momentumdan
pozitif momentuma geçmemizi sağladı
ve daha sonra Dünya çapında
şuan 55 ülkede kullanılan
bir insan sayma cihazı geliştirdik.
Şuan gün itibariyle 55'ten fazla ülkede
kullanılıyor.
Önümüzdeki yıl bu sayıyı 100'ün üstüne
çıkartmaya çalışıyoruz.
Belki Dünya'da kullanılan
yüksek teknoloji,
tamamen Türk üretimi
birkaç üründen bir tanesi.
Peki Onedio ne alaka, nasıl geldi?
Bir gün ben ofisteyim,
ODTÜ Teknokent'ten çeşitli
basın mensuplarını
başarılı firmalarla görüştürmeye
getiriyorlar.
Bize getirmişler.
Ben neler yaptığımızı anlatıyorum
basın mensuplarına.
Dedim ki işte insan sayma sistemleri
yapıyoruz,
trafik sistemleri yapıyoruz.
Bizim trafik sistemlerimiz de çok güzel.
Bir tane kamerayı koyuyorsun,
tüm yoldan geçen arabaların
plakalarını algılayabiliyorsun.
Çünkü yüksek çözünürlüklü
bir sistemimiz var.
Normal sistemler, İstanbul'da da
görmüşsünüzdür,
yolların üstünde konstrüksiyonlar vardır,
her şeride bakan bir tane kamera vardır.
Dedim ki: "Bunların arasından eğer
geçilirse kör nokta olduğu için
sistem okumayabiliyor."
Ha tamam falan, gittiler.
Ertesi gün bununla uyandım.
Tüm gazetelerde manşet:
Büyük kurnazlık! ODTÜ'lü bir firmanın
sahibi
EDS'yi yanıltma yöntemini buldu
falan filan.
Böyle tüm haberler şey yapıyor.
Beni bir yandan televizyon kanalları
arıyor, gelin ana haber bültenine çıkın.
Bu işi birlikte test edelim.
Bir yandan rektör arıyor. Ulan diyo sana
sistem anlat diye getirdim,
sen çakallık anlatmışsın.
Çünkü yorumlar falan,
haberlerde görseniz.
"İşte ODTÜ'lüler de böyle, kafası anca
çakallıklara çalışıyo." filan diye
millet giydirmiş.
Dedim ya hani
ben onu anlatmadım orada.
Ben aslında sistemin
ne kadar iyi olduğunu,
kendi avantajlarını anlattım.
Ama gazeteciler tabii bunu click yaratmak
için, okunmak için
bir şekilde kendilerine çevirmişler.
Herkesin aslında kendisini anlatabileceği,
neden geleneksel medyada
insanların haberlerini başkası yapıyor ki?
Herkes zaten sosyal medyada çok aktif.
Twitter, facebook...
Yani herkes, birer haber verme noktası
hâline dönüşmüş zaten.
Tek yapılması gereken bunu
bir çatı altında toplayalım,
firmalar girsin buraya,
gazeteciler girsin,
insanlar girsin kendi haberlerini,
kendi içeriklerini kendileri üretsinler
ve halk belirlesin hangi haber manşete
çıkacak, hangi haber çok popüler dedik,
Onedio'yu kurduk.
Yıl 2012.
Onedio'nun ilk hâli bu şekildeydi.
Tabii o zamanlar tamamen haber
üzerine odaklandığımız için,
insanlar haber yapsın, konular
üzerinde konuşsun,
haberciliği değiştirelim,
medyayı değiştirelim,
gazeteciliği değiştirelim gibi
bir vizyonumuz vardı.
Tabii kontrolü insanların eline bırakınca,
konuşmanın başında Esra Hanım'ın
bahsettiği gibi
daha eğlenceli, daha popüler,
daha vakit geçirmeye yönelik içerikler
konuşulmaya başlandı, onlar ön plana
çıkmaya başladı.
Onedio yavaş yavaş evrim
geçirmeye başladı.
Haberler her zaman oldu ama,
insanlar daha çok kendilerini ifade etmek
için içerik üretmeye başladılar.
Mesela geleneksel medyada asla
göremeyeceğiniz,
gerçekten İstanbul'da yaşayan;
bir transeksüel birey girip
Onedio'da profil oluşturup,
üzerine "İstanbul'da Transeksüel
Olmanın Zorlukları" diye
bir içerik oluşturabildi.
Geleneksel medyada bu nasıldı?
Ayşe Arman gider, bir transseksüelle
konuşur, bunu sansasyonel bir şekilde
köşesine taşır veya transeksüel
kılığına girer,
sokaklarda dolaşır, anılarını yazardı.
Yani bizde
gerçekten bir transseksüel kadın
yaşadığı zorlukları anlatabiliyor.
Bu tabii ki çok farklı noktalara geldi.
Gezi Parkı olaylarında mesela inanılmaz
patladı Onedio, o momentum.
Geleneksel medya gözlerini kapamışken
herkes gördüğü, bildiği şeyleri
Onedio'da paylaşmaya başladı.
Biz bunları derledik, insanlara sunduk.
Türkiye'den başlayıp İspanya'ya,
Japonya'ya kadar
çok büyük medya mecraları
Onedio'yu kaynak göstererek
Gezi Olayları'nı report eti.
Daha sonra tabii bu sistem kendisini
geliştirdiği için
daha çok insan içeri girdi,
daha çok insan içerik üretmeye başladı,
daha çok insan Onedio linki
paylaşmaya başladı
ve sadece 2 yılda Türkiye'nin en çok
ziyaret edilen 19. sitesi olduk.
Dünya'nın en çok ziyaret edilen ilk 1000
sitesi arasına girdik
ve bu sürekli yükselmeye devam ediyor.
Hedefimiz 2015 yılı içerisinde
ilk 10'a girmek.
Özetlemek gerekirse; hepimizin hayatında
kötü şeyler oluyor, bunun farkındayız.
Önemli olan oradan bir şekilde
çıkacağımızı bilip,
orada hep mutlu kalmak
ve geleceğe umutla bakmak.
Teşekkürler.
(Alkışlar)